très trop petit c'est dans les herbes
quand j'ai eu vent doux avance dans les
herbes je les vois pratiquement pas
les bras ou pas
tant
que ça un peu plus grave peut-être wet
wet wet
[ __ ] ils sont un peu ado j'appelle
encore à gauche voilà atp en date étant
la non non non non c'est la t2a 30 ans
regarde qu elle attend l'eau dans
l'herbe dans l'herbe cada voilà
allez on y va
arrêt dans l'eau pour santécois dans les
habits trop tôt ou trop tard on a tordu
vachement ententois
effet le rappeur ailleurs
il
fera
pas peur du tout
par ailleurs moins voire rien du
wassoulou la brèche est ouverte qu'aux
banques en europe à
salut bonjour toi
enfin on s'en veut
et il sera attaché à jour qui
ça peut donner un autre blessé le sultan
dont la santé les services ovi store à
bouillon à sortir voilà
au fond
voie pour sortir leur sortie encore
dressé depuis le cours
pivot phase bêta
à vérifier
la face aux retient
voir quand il a lâché 2 le coin mais à
la fin de leur départ en décalé dont
chloé opaque
et il sort ouais ouais c'est flou enfin
ils râlent point n'est pas loin achète
pas facile à faire le point sur les
tubes d'hier
alors il attend je coupais seconde page
je change de raï valdo vous avez
l'oiseau c'est super
passer devant
yves guillemot qui grimpe les marches
ou non
alors les deux là
les deux hockey à tous et toutes voilà
alors là c'est pas bon
c'est bon pas assez de monde en ce
moment et
beaucoup
de
frappes
au
sol
à
paris